so what's up it's nice being this close
to you man yeah same I like this I like
this new little setup we got going on
yeah me too you saw it you saw a chat
post a new video today Hanks yeah oh no
way he's like mentioned or something
what do you mean baby what what do you
mean
what's up
what were you guys saying about me
um nothing man we just you know nothing
we just
just uh
just stoked this is a pretty sick
spaceship you got thanks man thanks for
pulling out man thanks for having me bro
dude okay I was actually I did watch
this last night uh was this PR you just
put up on bench I I just started getting
back and working out and Cody's been
like on and on 3 15 3 15 dude are you
still waking up at like four yeah yeah
so why do you do that
oh I mean a couple reasons man
um first of all it's really difficult
for me I was I've never been a morning
person and I'm still not I'm still not
I'm not like one of those people that's
just like naturally like body clock
wakes them up that early I'm the
opposite like if I'm just left to my own
devices I can easily sleep like past
noon like any day of the week you know
what I mean so number one it's it's
difficult for me so the fact that it's
difficult for me
and that I still rise to the occasion
every single day it's like I'm setting
my day up for Success like I'm setting
my life up for Success I'm setting my
mentality up for Success because boom
right from the beginning I already
accomplished something that was
difficult like I already got a win you
know what I mean I already got a win
under my vote so do you kind of like
it's not even really about waking up
early it's almost like it's just a
commitment to yourself like you're gonna
get up and and you to yourself you're
you're proving like okay I'm gonna take
care of me yeah exactly it's a
commitment to myself and also like to
hold like my clients accountable because
people that join my program it's like
I'm showing them like look if I'm doing
it there's no reason why you can't
because I'm not going to ask them to do
anything that I'm not willing to do
myself so it's like showing them look
I'm I'm doing this [__] I mean I have to
lead by example if these people join my
program you know what I'm saying so it's
also to hold them accountable people hit
me up and they're like you know I need
accountability well it's like this is
this is the accountability aspect I'm
doing it so you should do it this is the
difference between like a personal
trainer and a coach right because some
people say I need accountability and
what they're expecting is someone to
like literally hit them up every day be
like did you do your workout come on get
in the gym let's do it like like if if
you need that type of motivation like
you're never gonna [__] you might as
well just give up people need to flick
that switch though I feel like they need
to flip the switch exactly I talk about
that a lot I feel like in a trainer and
[__] like helps them do that in the
beginning
and then you kind of like learn
oh I like this this is part of my [__]
like part of my routine now you know
well yeah I mean like a good coach like
that's what we're doing like when I post
my motivational content that's all I'm
trying to do I'm trying to flip that
switch and people I'm trying to activate
that you know just kick start them give
them that little push to like take the
actions and [__] stick to it that's
the important part because it's like
anybody can [__] get motivated to
change or whenever in any area like Not
Just Fitness or their diet but like in
getting sober and like building their
business whatever anything that's going
to take consistent hard work that's
gonna require them to like begin
something and not [__] fall off like
not fold how do you do in the beginning
because you like you were sober for a
while and then you weren't yeah and then
you kind of like did this transformation
yeah you know I went I went back and
forth myself like for a while that was
my whole thing dude it's like
my whole my whole pattern for my life
was like
I could string together some discipline
for a while
[__] would be going well everything
starts moving and then I just [__]
fall off I I know I [__] start
drinking again I start smoking weed
again doing drugs whatever so it'd be
like one step forward two steps back
constantly I run my life into a crisis
run myself into like a crisis mode then
be motivated to be like oh [__] I gotta
get my [__] together then I get my [__]
together for a while she'll be going
well and then I just repeat the same
cycle over and over again did you feel
like at any point in that in that phase
of your life did you feel like you
almost
would want that crisis to happen again
so you could get that feeling of taking
care of yourself that's a good point
because a lot of people do do that and I
I was I was doing that subconsciously as
well you know it's like it's like a
self-sabotaging
uh subconscious [__] thing going on
there because when you when you run your
life into a crisis you do get like you
know moments of extreme Clarity where
you're like okay this is what I I
[__] need to do because it's like
you're putting out fires it's like
Crisis management yeah but if you if you
if you if that's the only way you can
learn if the only way you can learn is
by putting yourself in a crisis that
you're actually you're you're moving
backwards you're not moving forwards
because you take one step forward and
two steps back so over time you're
you're getting worse and worse the key
is to like literally [__] get to a
point where you no longer need to
[__] run your life into a crisis in
order to [__] make the changes that
you know you need to make and and uh
like the the the harsh truth of that is
that really like what that requires is
like basically
getting to a crisis that's like so bad
that like you realize that like you
can't ever [__] push this envelope
ever again and that's what happened with
me you know what was yours I just
[__] bro I just went on such a crazy
binge I was up for like three days and
three nights straight I didn't sleep I
didn't I didn't I was [__] partying
like doing coke Molly like whatever for
like three days and three nights
straight I didn't sleep I didn't eat
anything I barely even drank any water
and like I went way way out you know
what I mean I was I went way out there
no it was terrible it was [__]
terrible because at the end of that [__]
you start losing your mind and it's it's
[__] scary it's like you start going
into psychosis like I was hearing I was
[__] I didn't even know what was real
anymore I was having auditory
hallucinations
I didn't I was hearing like voices like
I didn't even know what the [__] was
real anymore it was it was terrifying
it's really terrifying they say it's
like
um extreme like sleep deprivation is
like basically what you're experiencing
is basically like what it feels like to
be schizophrenic
it's like visiting schizophrenia damn
it's really [__] scary dude because
you it's like you you feel like you're
like in a living hell like you literally
don't know what's real and what's not it
became very clear to me then that it's
like if I continue this way then like my
life is gonna be a [__] absolute
disaster like something really really
bad is gonna happen I just knew it like
something really bad was gonna happen
either like I you know I was gonna die
some way or like I would just make do
something like so stupid that like my
life would be over basically yeah you
know and I would be dealing with some
cons I could feel like consequences like
major drastic consequences coming that
would have been like life ruiners you
know what I'm saying so like um that
there's like no coming back from so I
just realized then that I was like I
needed to make a drastic change and uh
that's why you know like kind of like
the way I you know live my life is
pretty intense these days because I have
to be intense I have to be I have to
keep that intensity to you know keep
myself on a positive track you know I
got a question I think that humanizes
anybody
are you ticklish
[Laughter]
you know it's weird dude like
depends on who's tickling me yeah
are you ticklish that's a really good
response yeah yeah I yeah I am yeah are
you yeah but I'm kind of I think I'm in
that camp I think it's like it depends
okay like some people could and it would
just
but it's it's kind of a weird thing like
some other people could take away
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's true stop it right now yeah
or if you know the Zone yeah you know
that was a good segue that was a really
good we could pretty much talk about
anything no I mean I'm just it's just
I was talking about it with my with my
wife last night so weird to call her
that we just got married but
congratulations thanks man we were
laughing at that question because we're
like you forget people are ticklish you
know like even just like like think of
the coolest person you think like is
future ticklish he might be yeah we
don't know huh that's a good point
imagine future getting just like tickled
in the armpit just giggling on a
stripper yeah and he's like
I'm trying to think of
like the one person
that would just be like mind-blowing if
he was like if Putin was ticklish that'd
be crazy dude he definitely is man do
you think Putin's taking yeah he's like
short and like us you know so what are
you saying if you're under five nine
you're automatically probably ticklish
yeah yeah like you have more surface
area it's like harder to you know find
the Zone yeah you're what how does she
wait right now 210. yeah you got to like
tickle hard like you know what I'm
saying get around them yeah you gotta
like really you got to get in there you
put I I guess if there's any motivation
to get ripped dude like if you're a
hyperticulous person you gotta get
massive yeah it's like armor against
yeah yeah come and try to tickle me
[__] like you can't good luck
yeah
foreign